la promesse était de planter deux
milliards d'arbres
vous en avez plus en plus combien je
vais maintenant on en a planté d'abord
planté des arbres faux faux faux l'époux
c'est d'abord ça prend un certain
montant pour on peut pas tout simplement
planté des graines vous regardez déjà
combien d'arbres ont été plantés jusqu'à
maintenant
[Musique]
au moins 800 milles
c'est une promesse que les libéraux en
fait à montréal pendant la campagne
électorale de 2010 neuf changements si
vous l'aimez rhône ont
ce jour là centaines de milliers de
personnes ont manifesté pour le climat
aux côtés de greta de solberg
gouvernement libéral réélu plantera deux
milliards d'arbres au cours des dix
prochaines années en février dernier
ottawa a lancé un premier appel d'offres
pour la plantation de 30 millions
d'arbres d'ici la fin de l'année
combien ont réellement été planté
jusqu'à présent on ignore avec précision
parce que le ministère des ressources
naturelles est incapable de répondre à
la question
cet été cette entente qui prévoit la
plantation de deux millions d'arbres ont
été dévoilés publiquement
on a contacté les groupes sélectionnés
et on a réussi à confirmer qu'au moins
800 8200 arbres ont été plantés dans le
cadre du programme mais il pourrait y en
avoir plus
les libéraux auront seulement rempli un
ennemi pour cent de leurs promesses
s'ils parviennent à planter 30 millions
d'arbres cette année comme prévu
il va rester un milliard 970 millions
d'arbres à planter d'ici 2030 ses 246
millions d'arbres par année la cadence
devra donc s'accélérer
le gouvernement fédéral a mis de côté
plus de 3 milliards de dollars pour la
plantation de deux milliards d'arbres et
selon le directeur parlementaire du
budget ça va coûter environ deux fois
plus cher
[Musique]